the new book you're releasing your
second book a seriously good chili
cookbook yes in september
uh i didn't know you were you're like
your character you're a chili aficionado
i'm a chili aficionado yes the character
is and um
has become a
a big
meme
gif gift gift
yeah um you know it's just become one of
these
one of the moments from the show and so
i
you know i think the first couple of
times was really like
let me let me do it for the gram right
like i'm gonna make some chili and take
a couple pictures and
this will be fun right um and then i do
enjoy cooking i i i love to cook it is i
would love to taste it
i mean
don't just even
say it like that i mean
but you have compiled that says
177 of the world's best
chili recipes from celebrity chefs
restaurant owners chili cook-off winners
dedicated fans and of course himself yes
that's crazy i so i have my own recipe
they they have the the recipe from from
the show or or best their best guess of
it but no so a year or so ago
i went this is a thing that exists and
not only does it exist
it's like
i should have done my research it's like
60 years
give or take a couple of years
the world championship chili cook-off
exists in this country sponsored by the
international chile society it's been
going around 50 to 60 years
and
there's a competition
for like world the world champion and so
everyone who is there
is a winner right like everyone has one
they're local they're fire house the you
know the firefighters have one there's
um you know their region their state
their whatever and there's like a
hundred of you're there's a field and
there's just people cooking chili
everywhere and you're like tasting it
and trying to evaluate it and and i
judged it
um and it was a crazy
crazy experience but so much fun and the
passion that people have for i think
because it takes time and i think in a
lot of ways the longer it takes the
better it and so it becomes very
communal it becomes very family whether
that's like your actual family or like
the your friends or whatever the people
who enjoy it too
um it's something you share i love it i
just there's the culture of it i love i
just love and there's like
beans or no beans or you know green
beans or meatless and meat and turkey
and this it's a million ways you can
yeah well there's at least 177
177 that's fantastic um so yeah i i i
had so much fun uh putting that together
and uh
yeah coming out coming out september
13th a seriously good chili cookbook let
me just ask you is
your chili would you think it would
compete with some of the top chili
makers in the world
yeah why not
yeah
i mean i don't mess around how long does
it take to you to make a bowl of chili
um
well
you know typically you make a pot of it
not just a bowl sorry um
can you imagine just you're literally
chilling you're literally just measuring
out enough meat for one bowl
um
i would say
i mean there's a certain point in time
where i do think like the longer you let
it go
for my recipe the longer you let it go
just the better it is if you have more
time so like
ideally i'm starting late morning and
gonna do it in the evening and just let
it just just let it just just get all up
in there and just hit flavors if you
ever invite me to where you live for
some chili i would go okay if you ever
have a party chili party or chili party
chili gathering okay